hey you guys it's monday this monday you
know what that means that's some
haunting [ __ ]
yeah
yeah this is going to be a good show
because this is one of the better this
is one of the better episodes i had
actually forgotten all about this one
somebody recommend i don't remember who
it was but somebody recommended this one
because i made a list i think there's
like five other ones that people
recommended so we were just kind of like
randomly so this was just kind of like
the first one when we were digging
through the
uh the dvd set this is just the first
one that was on the recommended list
that came up so we say [ __ ] it we'll
just watch this one which is called
stalked by evil yeah i hate when i'm
stalked by evil doesn't it yeah and uh
in this one it's basically basically um
cute girl
being stalked by an evil ghost
and they got a cute little chick
playing her and then when you see the
the real girl she's even cuter so it's a
good it's it's a good it's a good
episode which like i said they don't
usually do that usually and i'm just
just no like no no shade or anything
like that you're not gonna shade on a
girl but but no i'm not talking about
her in particular i'm just saying that
like no shade but uh normally
you see the actors actresses in the
thing and then like you see the real
person and you're just like oh well yeah
kind of you know but you know what i
mean yeah i don't really want to say
anything
but you know what i mean but in this
case well the girl i mean she doesn't
really look like her because the girl
that they got to play her was like a
blonde who actually like looked a lot
like my one of my cousins at least when
she was a kid yeah and a little twiggy
little thing she's cool looking and uh
the actual girl kind of looked like a
little bit like avril lavigne or
something yeah yeah yeah
and
it's funny we were watching and i was
reanalyzing the case and
it has some similarities to poltergeist
phenomenon
the focus is definitely a young girl a
charismatic young girl
um
this may have been poltergeist although
steve steve mara parapsychologist that
jenny's written books with and who's
kind of a friend of mine online friend
of mine
he said there are some cases that are
seem to be kind of in between
which that'd be
spooky you know that
the one that my family witnessed was
classic poltergeist which was a fake
ghost there was no ghost there but it
was definitely moving objects but that's
another story
um
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis of
the subconscious mind and
this one
could have been that
it could it could be rspk
but there were certain elements of it
that
kind of
i don't know a poultry guys could do
this it could but so we'll
we'll talk about it
um but before we get into the shows i
wanted to uh thank some of the people
that show up early well the uh
uh the countdown's beginning well while
the soothing music is yeah listening to
it too you know and getting ready and
[ __ ] i'm seeing who's showing up and
go let's go they're in there waiting so
it's already it's firing us up because
it kind of sucks to go on stage
uh before a [ __ ] empty [ __ ]
audience see what i mean at least
somebody's hearing you live so
i don't worry about it too much because
like i said i mean i recorded something
i make a lot of videos so i just kind of
like imagine because i'm just i mean
really to be fair i'm just like sitting
here in front of my laptop like in my
office
so but i imagine you guys like listening
to me talking i like i like i like a
live audience though it adds a different
dynamic to it yeah i am like i said i am
glad that we started doing the sidetrack
shows and like two well
i don't know like the having the regular
shows be live like that's kind of like a
double-edged sword like i said because i
do like it because i like the
interaction with everybody but it's like
so easy to get distracted and like i get
frustrated because i'm like we're
supposed to be talking about the topic
you know yeah so it's but i don't know
so i i don't know if i'd want to go back
to doing recorded though but
they're good for some things yeah when
you have to do it but i mean that's why
that's why i went back to doing like
recorded like true crime [ __ ] like on my
new crime memorial channel and why i
went back to doing recorded horror [ __ ]
like on my scarecrow channel was just
because i was like well i want to be
able to like make videos that are more
focused on one thing and then i don't
have to like worry about it as much
because you know how i do it like i
worry about anything well if you can do
them live you might want to do them live
because you can get a super chat i mean
i might someday yeah uh when the
channels get bigger yeah but that's
right they're not really monetized yet
so it doesn't no i haven't monetized
them yet so it's just like i'm not well
i can't monetize them yet because i
don't have enough subscribers no no
subscribers so please uh and subscribe
yeah and honestly the crime memorial one
i only just today put up the fifth video
now the scarce along one has more
because that was been up for a month
longer but like i said i'm i'm doing
good like keeping stuff
putting two new videos up every week
yeah and i'm working on thursday's video
today i gotta record it tomorrow i also
wanted to give uh some information to my
boy louie louie hernandez he's [ __ ]
over the years he's sent us [ __ ] some
of the some of the best movies some of
these movies i've never even seen him
before [ __ ] and he'll send me and i
go well it's coming from louise i know
this shit's going to be good yeah he's
got like an excellent taste yeah he's
got he's got good taste and [ __ ]
turns out like so much just some of my
favorite movies you know
uh [ __ ]
uh anyway he uh
louie you sent me uh
uh the untouchables yeah untouchable
from 1987.
i couldn't get it to play in the in the
uh xbox
and then i looked at it well of course
it's 4k yeah it's 4k so it won't play we
don't have a 4k television not yet not
yet i think i think xbox can probably
download a 4k player as a as a an app
but the problem is i don't have a 4k uh
television uh but don't worry we're
gonna review it anyway because uh one it
comes with a digital copy if i have to
go that route but it's also on hbo max
and i have hbo max so we'll throw my
phone plan we'll just watch it on hbo
max and you'll get your review if you
guys buy me a movie you know especially
you know he sent me a 4k [ __ ]
steelbook okay you're gonna get a review
all right we're gonna watch that that
gets moved to the front um i mean we
still gotta do godfather two and
godfather we gotta do god father two and
three we're we haven't got around
there's so much [ __ ] we gotta watch man
but uh yeah remind me about that we'll
do that father two yeah but we'll do the
untouchables tomorrow because like i
said after we discovered that the disc
wouldn't play because we don't have the
i couldn't put on the 4k tv yeah yeah
cause i was like it's a brand new disc
because like there's nothing wrong with
it so you're looking at the back yeah
this thing's perfect and then it said 4k
and i was like wait hold on that's not
blue ray and i'm looking it doesn't have
any blu-ray symbols is there another no
it's just 4k
i can't play it yet i don't have a 4k
television but it'll go in with the
collection
all with the other ones eventually we'll
get a 4k television and then we can
watch it
but like i said it's on hbo max so we
can watch it tonight on hbo usually
when i buy blu-rays or dvds it's to go
into a hard copy collection this is like
a collection like a library
yeah he has a big thing in his man cave
that's all yeah right
most of them i won't watch again or if i
do watch it it's years later
uh but watching them is not really what
i'm doing i'm kind of like
storing up all my best movies curing and
curating
for safety you know what i mean like
like a seed in noah's ark in case the
[ __ ] world ends i got that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] hard copy we'll watch it again
that kind of stuff but no i like to
collect things and um i like to collect
real good movies ones that i like the
other ones that are kind of iffy i i'll
trade those out or sell them or whatever
but the good ones yeah i keep them and i
got a whole [ __ ]
big
big
like like yeah i'm kind of honestly i'm
kind of the same way with books
um as you can see in all kinds of books
yeah
moving's a [ __ ] you guys
[Laughter]
it had to be like a thousand several
thousand probably but it's probably like
a ton it wouldn't surprise me she's got
book cabinets in here that are sagging
under the weight i know well here's the
thing though i mean i will absolutely
read ebooks and i do like you know
because i have to read a lot of books
for you know for my uh book review show
so i'm just like well i can't afford to
buy all these books much as i might like
to uh so i'm like i'm gonna kindle
unlimited man like what do you have on
there for free like ebooks but even then
like i will read ebooks but i always
prefer like having a book book i really
like having like the physical copy so
over the years i have bought 50
bajillion million books and you would be
shocked but
i think
98
of every book in here i have read at
least once xanada the desert fox is out
there
um he's i've known he's been an online
friend for a long time i helped him with
his ar-15 builds and stuff
um and he's living out in the damn
[ __ ] desert of america i think he i
think he lives in nevada utah forgot
which one it was
but or arizona i think it's arizona but
um
uh he's asking me to watch old country
no country culture that's a great
[ __ ] i saw it but it was a been a
while i don't remember much about it uh
so
yeah if somebody sends it to me it will
go to the front it'll go to the front of
the line but i got other [ __ ] that
people paid for reviews for
gotta hit that first i remember it being
pretty good but i also remember that i
wasn't really paying real close
attention to it
i think i started a lot of surprises
yeah
i think i started liking it after it had
already begun and i was like well hold
on what's going on i just got to see it
again i love that movie i've seen it
like three or four times on this point
it's just i never get tired of it it's
it's so good uh blackrock said oh if you
two need any of the later haunting
episodes i have everything up to season
seven i think
we have everything up to season
six or seven maybe i know some of them i
have let me go see how many like i said
i had i bought him a box set that was
the first four seasons
and then i bought him
separate seasons like onto because after
a while they didn't do box sets anymore
because by that point like you know uh
physical media had kind of started going
out the window so i bought him season
five like individually i think and then
i bought him season six i think i bought
him season seven two but i don't really
remember he's gonna go look right now
but i think like the rest of them we did
watch them but we don't have the
physical copy i think we have everything
up to season seven two though
but usually i mean the first four
seasons are the ones that we like watch
the movies
yeah that's one through four right i
remember buying that then i got that's
season six that's season six i remember
this one just says 2012 which one is
that
season seven
the 2012 season that's season five five
so we got them all five and six so we
don't have season seven we don't have
seasons i could have sworn i bought you
season seven
i didn't tell you you had to go check i
was just saying
i could have sworn that i bought you
season seven but maybe i didn't like it
was a long time ago
so we definitely have one through six
but i don't we may or may not have seven
and i'm not entirely sure i think we've
seen most of them up to because i've
we've watched some of the newer ones
like on we watched some of the newer
ones when they were on
like when we used to watch cable but you
know what i mean
uh there was also a spin-off called
alaska haunting oh yeah i kind of
remember that i remember that did they
really have so many yes you got seven
two see that's what i thought okay i'm
not i'm not crazy and then three more
seasons that's i'm not crazy and i think
season eight we checked and season eight
was not available yeah i think after
season seven they didn't offer them as
physical media anymore like you can buy
them they might not through
well no i mean you can buy them through
itunes or you can um you know watch them
on i think you can watch them on pluto
they might have they might they might
offer them on on dvd now maybe that was
a long time ago that's true it was a
long time ago we checked that's true if
somebody could check for us
and drop it in the comment section
senator said he's going to send no
country for old men okay yeah if you're
saying that i'll watch it
i love it seriously it's really good i
mean i'm a big fan of the coen brothers
like every movie of theirs that i've
seen i've really really liked we'll do
i'll do a review and an analysis i know
what you want to hear you want to know
how you know if the gun play was correct
you want to know [ __ ] about the guns
i'll tell you about the guys
yeah but the thing about it is that the
movie is kind of about i mean it has
like a lot of deeper themes and i think
that you might like to be about like
fate and aging and stuff like that okay
i'll check you might like really okay
yeah and it has like a really good
villain
yeah okay
um
i was also uh we we reviewed uh pray the
other day
and uh
went and thought about it and then i
watched uh [ __ ] carl benjamin's
analysis of it and wanted to come back
in and say yeah man pookie's [ __ ]
running up and down i know that's what i
was like was that poop she was jumping
over the [ __ ] thing and everything
she's jumping now
we don't call her her to buffalo for
nothing
if you haven't seen prey go ahead and
see it that's the best you're gonna get
from hollywood nowadays it's not perfect
um
but if you do see it
see it with
the cherokee dub no it's commander the
command [ __ ] up the comanche dub
sounds a lot better and it
the comanches that are in it
when they start talking in english i
mean it's california you can tell those
[ __ ] are from california
and um it kind of
it was okay but it kind of didn't feel
very authentic
um
but in in in
comanche it sounded a lot better
yeah i mean it is dubbed which is always
a little bit distracting but i get it it
was a lot more immersive like you said
well the thing about it is that as far
as i know like all the actors in there
were native american um but just i don't
know if any of them were comanche though
like i know that the lead girl was sue
right um but i don't really know
what tribe the other ones what carl
brought up though and he was absolutely
right he said it still kind of lost some
visual authenticity
because when you look at them they are
definitely modern people if you put them
up against native americans of the era
they were a lot harder
looking you know what i mean because
they were yeah but you know they were
living in the wild and they were just i
just appreciate that they actually got
native american actors to play native
american characters i just wish they
would have made those [ __ ] work
out some and get them rougher looking
you know
and uh because
if predator one was a [ __ ]
masterpiece and we're just waiting for
people to show up so we're just feeling
some time predator one was a masterpiece
because all those dudes in that movie
were either ex-soldiers or some kind of
professional athlete they actually
people say oh man they're jacked they
look like bodybuilders now
no mercenaries would look like that they
take reds they take all kinds of special
forces dudes were taking roids they
didn't get that big some of them but
arnold wasn't that big but no they
looked like they were comfortable
because they were the real thing it's a
felt
predator one is an authentic movie
and the script was written by infantry
guys that slip that underneath the
[ __ ] door of a dab
studio and they would yeah yeah we'll
make that and it what it was evidently
was
some infantry guys
were out in the field training and they
said man what if we were out here doing
this training and some alien hunter was
[ __ ] hunting us down they were
inspired by a movie called without
warning where that was happening and
alien was hunting people that's on
shutter we should probably review that
we got to review it right it's actually
not a bad movie for for the
budget i remember liking it
and that's what inspired him is it
charles band though i think so the same
guy that did transfers i think so which
was it might have been not great
[Laughter]
so the
predator one had an authenticity to it
um
prey is good
that's the best you're gonna get it has
problems but that's the best you're
gonna get right now it's just because
the people making them are soft you know
they're soft you know
just how it is you know but they did i
think it is okay it's okay i liked it it
was a lot better than the predator
even though i liked elements of that one
uh it was a mixed bag it was good [ __ ]
and bad [ __ ] mixed together
predator two is okay
i liked avp one and two i thought those
were really good
and uh i really liked uh
predators the one where they were on the
[ __ ] hunting planet i thought that
was really good not perfect but really
good
block frog says your cat looks just like
mine yeah is your cat also a mix or does
your cat have a tail
a little pot-bellied makes a little
cause our kitty is a little yeah we
sometimes call her all ball because she
does kind of she's very everything is
round she's very round yeah she has a
little pouch well she has
you call it a pot belly i call it her
pouch yeah
[Laughter]
and she has little bitty short legs and
her little stumpy tail that she wags
like a little puppy dog
evidently there's a spin-off called
alaska haunting yeah i know i already
addressed that oh did you go it must
have been running out there yeah danny
rowling said stalked by an evil predator
yeah that's pretty much where this is
going i guess
so all right can we like talk about the
actual topic now or what
yeah good okay we're ready there's
enough people there buzz has a tail oh
okay yeah yeah pokey does not have the
tail because she's a manx she's a stumpy
mix and i thought that that was like
just a made up like mean term but that's
actually technically what they're called
because there are three kind of mechs
there's actually monks that have a tail
then there's mags with no tail at all
like just a little round butt and then
like you have the stumpy manx which is
what she is with where this tail is just
a little stump like an inch so that's
what she is
all right so
this is stalked by evil we're stalked by
evil
season 4 episode 10.
now i don't know i'm not encouraging
anybody to go look this up but i was
kind of curious about the history of
this house and where exactly this house
was i will admit that the house they
used on the show it's obviously not the
real house but it's similar to the
houses like in the neighborhood because
i did like google earth that [ __ ] and
like do the street view and all that now
according to
some random [ __ ] on pinterest
uh they took a picture of the real house
and they said and i don't know if this
is true or not they said the real house
they didn't give the address but they
said it was in the 1200 block of hayward
drive and this is in corpus christi
texas
now i went on google street view and i
looked all along hayward drive it's not
very long it's just like a little like a
little curve road like that with like a
dead end
or you know like a cul-de-sac at the end
and so i went and i couldn't find i
couldn't match
the house the houses that i saw like i
looked at all of them and i couldn't
match it to the picture but it could
just be because the picture was old and
like maybe one of the trees that was in
the front was cut down and it got
painted or something like that because
all the houses kind of look the same so
i don't really know if that's exactly
the street that the house is on but
that's what i heard because there wasn't
a huge amount of supplemental material
about this particular case nobody wrote
a book about it there was nothing like
that
so
but the house apparently is on haber
drive in corpus christi i don't know if
that's true or not but that's what the
person on pinterest said
so this story took place in
2005.
now this is about the mccarthy family
now they had been living in corpus
christi in like a little bitty apartment
and what ended up happening they bought
or actually i don't even think they
bought it i think they rented it because
they said they were talking to a
landlord later on so i guess they
decided to like rent a bigger house
like in the same town
now the mom judy she's a stay-at-home
mom
um and she has a husband named john
who's like some kind of like diesel
mechanic like supervisor or something
like that and then they have a 17 year
old daughter named caressa
and
also
she has a grown daughter named lisa
lambert who has a son of her own named
jacob okay so everybody like figure that
out like all the [ __ ] flow chart of
the family all right yeah
now what ended up happening one of the
things that necessitated the move from
the apartment to this bigger house
lisa the grown daughter she got laid off
she was like a human resources recruiter
or something like that
so she had been living she was a single
mom and she was living with her son
jacob who looked like i don't know how
old he was at the time in the show he
looked like he was probably 11 12. how
like that kid look i think he was like
11 or 12. he looked like a preteen
so uh she lost her job and she was like
okay well i'm broke ass now and so she
ended up having to move in with john and
judy who were her parents her parents
and she brought the boy yeah and so she
had to bring the boy she's like not
permanently but like temporarily all the
time yeah until she could get another
job and like get a place of their own so
they had moved into the apartment i
think and had been sleeping on the floor
so the parents are like yeah this [ __ ]
this noise we're gonna get like get a
bigger house so they got a bigger house
because the apartment they've been
living in was only two bedroom one bath
and i can imagine how that was like a
big [ __ ] nightmare
so
they moved to this new house
now caressa the same 17 year old girl
she's super into the new house she's
like is in the same school district so
she doesn't have to change schools or
anything like that and apparently there
was all there was like an addition to
the living room
so
lisa the grown daughter and the her son
like had kind of their own little area
that could be kind of like closed off
from the rest of the house so they still
kind of had their own like privacy and
they liked that
now there was also they kind of brought
this up on the show and i thought that
it was going to factor more into i guess
it factors a little bit into it but not
so much
so they have this whole thing where judy
was hanging up this little lantern and
it belonged to her dad who had passed
away several years previously
and she just like hung it in the living
room and she's like it was very special
to her because i guess her and her dad
used to go fishing when she was a kid
and like i said he had died and she got
this lantern so
they so she hung it like in the living
room like i said i thought something was
gonna happen without lantern later on
but it didn't really but they did kind
of make a big deal about like this
lantern or
whatever now much like a lot of other
episodes of haunting and i wonder if
they pick and choose
because the family dynamic is always
kind of like this because it always
seems like
the dad of the family is always like
he's like never home like he always like
works super long hours or he works night
shifts and that is indeed the case in
this like the dude is just never there i
don't know if they write that into the
show because the dude didn't want to be
on the show because he's not interviewed
the mom is and the daughter is
actually both daughters are the grown
daughter and the uh the younger daughter
they both got interviewed and the mom
did as well but nobody else like not the
dad not the kid not the little boy kid
not anybody else so maybe they just kind
of like wrote him out of the [ __ ] i
don't know
because they kind of made him look like
a dick on this show maybe he was a dick
i don't really know
but so just like in most of these uh the
dad is just like i don't think he works
the night shift but he's gone a lot you
know what i mean like he leaves early in
the morning and he's just like um you
know works all day so there's that kind
of thing
now
the first thing that happens so there's
one morning where
okay i'm kind of confused by this so
like everybody
had left the house for either work or
school except caressa i think
but so judy she's a stay-at-home mom so
she's still at home and she's like
cleaning up after breakfast or whatever
the [ __ ]
and she said that she heard very clear
footsteps like kind of clomping through
the house
now she said
and this is a quote from the show she
said it was a hard step like a man
walking with boots on like she heard
somebody like clomping through the house
with boots on
now she thought her husband had
forgotten something and like came back
to the house
and then she looks all around the house
and nobody's there
now originally i thought absolutely
nobody was in the house but it turns out
that caressa was still in the house at
this point because i guess she was like
scrambling around like trying to get
ready to go to school and she was going
to be late and blah blah because there
was some other [ __ ] that happened here
too
so
you know it's not clear i don't think
she heard whatever footsteps there were
i don't know if it was her who knows now
one of the things that she said was that
she lost her little her uh compact you
know i mean the little thing with the
powder in it like we put makeup yeah
and she's like rushing around looking
for it because you know you can't go to
[ __ ] school shiny i i get that so
she's running around looking for it
she's like i just had the [ __ ] and it's
not here
so she's looking all over um and then
she said she looked all over the house
freaking out and then she comes back
into the bathroom where she just was and
she's like and it was sitting right
there like on the edge of the sink
she said it it looked like it had been
left there deliberately yeah for me to
find it because she's like it absolutely
was not there before because i had just
come out of there that's classic poultry
poltergeist phenomenon rspk that what
she's describing is this a poltergeist i
don't know i don't know yet i haven't
really totally
i'll talk about it at the end at the end
of the program
but
haunting usually doesn't have that most
hauntings nothing is actually physically
moved
you just see apparitions figures hear
voices nothing ever moves
so something moving
i lean towards poltergeist like
disappearing and then really appearing
and disappearing yeah and usually we've
had that happen yeah
you usually don't see it in flight
although sometimes you do you don't see
it moving
it's just in one place and you turn
around somewhere else
or something disappears and then you
find it in a
impossible place like it was meant for
you to find it
like something was sending you a signal
that's poltergeist
but
i'm gonna get into it later steve mara
says that sometimes hauntings can do
that
but like he said he's never seen that
himself it's just based upon witness
testimony all this is theory based about
witness testimony and testimony is hard
to
sift through well because you know what
your objective the subjective you know
what you saw you know what people around
you see it's hard to really get nailed
down what somebody else saw a long time
ago in a place far away
you're just reading stories you know
yeah that's different but there are
patterns there's patterns to those
stories
even though not all the stories are true
once you know the pattern you can fake
them
you can fake a story
there's a lot of problems in
parapsychology
because of that
an expert can fake a fake a story just
pull it out of nowhere
yeah because you know like the
parameters you know like you know what
can be yeah you know what usually
happens in these yeah you know what to
lie about danny rowling said quick
question was the michael caine film
where he asked is he [ __ ] you that's
the hand it's the hand that's the hand
yes i am from is he [ __ ] you yeah
what was that 1981 right
he asked earlier but i think he got
retracted he's like let me guess they
had like an overweight psychic played by
a not overweight actress actually in
this one the psychic was skinny because
they actually had the real i mean she
wasn't a psychic she just ran a
paranormal thing uh she didn't claim to
be psychic or anything and actually in
this case like the actress that got to
play her looked a lot like the actual
woman this is one of the better episodes
and she was actually like thank you she
wasn't fab but i know what you're
talking about it's one of the better
episodes
this is an episode that stood out to me
and once i had forgotten about it but
then like once we started watching it
like it was one of the three that we
have on the list that's been requested
and then when i went oh yeah that one
when i looked at it and saw it oh yeah i
remember that one
yeah yeah so this is like towards the
top this is one this is a cream of the
crop
this this case yeah and like i said it
was one of the five that i had written
down that you guys had recommended and
it was just the first one that we did
and the episode is good yeah it's eerie
the way they filmed it and the way they
set it up like look
a haunting is
this isn't what you do research with you
know what i mean this is
the the haunting was a series to tell
you about cases of what supposedly
happened and then they presented it in a
really entertaining way it was [ __ ]
spooky they just wanted to be spooky
right but it's kind of on you to go
through the details of what actually
happened because
a haunting's
pretty good at sticking to
certain things but
they took liberties here and there i
mean they just want it to be like a
creepy entertaining show right if the
[ __ ] that you described is too boring
they're gonna ramp up then they're gonna
like gilded the
lily a little bit they're gonna know
we're gonna be they're gonna take some
artistic license
sure
uh blackrock said i'd love for you two
to review fear house
that's episode two right okay yeah right
firehouse was the one where they kept
seeing the damn clown
i think
i don't want to be seen figure out
clowns in my house i think that's one
way they saw the clown [ __ ] clowns
well that might have been hell house
they all have similar names
like sometimes if you tell me the name
of the episode i'm like i can't remember
which one
it is unless you tell me hey it was the
one that took place in this city that
where they had this and that then i'll
remember but they have such generic
titles yeah here's the funny thing in
the episode they showed an evil clown
but they didn't really make it clear
whether or not they reported it as a
clown they said yeah the clown freaked
me out that's what i mean it might have
been maybe that episode came out around
the time of that whole like ooh we're
seeing clowns like yeah dressed as
clowns kind of scared yeah cause
sometimes you go back into the case and
look at it says the witnesses never said
anything about a clown but they they
would put that [ __ ] in there i don't
remember that we don't know we haven't
investigated it yet i'm just saying that
haunting would do that kind of [ __ ]
they'd put some stuff in yeah that's the
thing and i know like i said and i think
i brought this up before but it's just
kind of like i know that they probably
do hours and hours of interviews with
the witnesses and then they kind of just
edit it down to whatever so but so i
don't know how much of the interviews
that they use
that they don't show them saying it but
then they do like um then they'll show
like whatever it is because i said
sometimes they'll show like a
reenactment
and
they'll be like a ghost like walking
behind the person i'm like yeah but they
didn't say they saw that then right they
just put that oh they just put that in
before i forget go ahead and like the
video people that that really help us
out like and interact thank you
nicholas says the presents is one of my
favorite episodes it's really creepy
okay yeah okay i'm gonna write that one
down too like i said i got a i got a
list that's ongoing so
we have i think four or five on there
now and then this is probably six and
seven or so you're helping us out you're
helping us out people so we can order so
yeah the popular ones right so like i
said we're making a list so if we don't
get to it like next week we'll
eventually get to it we're going to get
to all the ones that go if you guys want
us to [ __ ] review classic ones if you
want us to go back and look through
summer wind again
summer wind might be good to reformat it
i don't [ __ ] know but
we'll see we'll just see how it goes um
i'm open to redoing one of the older
ones that was a long time ago the
recording quality wasn't that good and
we we could probably pull up more on it
i mean we did a couple shows on summer
wind though because we had that guy on
that okay
that was like on the summer wind like
they were trying to like raise all the
money to get it rebuilt or whatever
because that's right he wanted to
rebuild summer wind on the old [ __ ]
yeah yeah
all right so uh
yeah so
uh caressa said that
she couldn't find her compact and then
she looked everywhere for it and it
wasn't anywhere and then all of a sudden
she goes back in the bathroom it's
sitting there again
so she was weirded out by that
now over the next few days or weeks or
whatever um caressa said that she
started feeling really uneasy in her
room at night um like someone was
watching her like per in specifically
like from her closet
so because of this she can't really get
any sleep so she's kind of like always
tired and she's getting like kind of
cranky all the time which like i said i
feel that
now one morning
after everybody has left for work or
school or whatever
judy is in the living room
and the tv keeps turning on by itself
and like not just turning on by itself
but like actually flipping through
channels the hilarious thing and i
remember i don't think i brought this up
on one of the other episodes but another
episode that we talked about did this
too
that the tv was coming on by itself
and i was like oh how funny that every
single show that it's flipping to has
the same narrator yeah yeah yeah as
that's haunting whose name is anthony
call by the way yeah he's now a legend
he's got a great [ __ ] voice well
because he does i think he does some
like true crime shows too like on
investigation discovery or whatever he
started talking about we we started
talking about this a few weeks back
there were people in the damn chats that
knew his name yeah
i knew his name because i just saw it
well i mean through the course of like
doing research about these shows and i
also found out that there's a soundtrack
for every season that has all the scores
from like every single episode
and yeah i even saw a picture of the guy
he didn't look anything like i expected
but they never do he's on his voice is
on par with keith david that's why he's
got a great [ __ ] voice yeah and like
i said i think keith david from the
thing
from the thing that motherfucker's voice
is badass did all this all this true
crime fit all the true crime of voice
overs
keith david was the [ __ ] man
and as a kid watching the thing i never
would have thought that that dude would
have
ended up being doing voice-overs
for true crime you know what i mean yeah
you don't think that like that you know
he just says well tough [ __ ] you
know just
well like i said i mean well and anthony
call who does this show i'm pretty sure
he does
it's not cold case files what's that
other one god damn it it was one i think
it's on investigation discovery but it's
been on for a long time but it's like a
true crime show and he does so that it's
funny because they'll show like hey he's
flipping through the channel i'm like
hey this one also has anthony calderon
well because that's what they have the
rights to i guess so it's just kind of
like they're just fluid so i just
thought that was kind of funny so anyway
so judy um the tv comes on and it keeps
flipping through channels she's like huh
that's weird
and so she thinks that
it's maybe something to do with the
remote control like maybe the remote
control is broken or maybe it needs some
new batteries or something like that so
she changes the batteries out
now a few weeks apparently go by and
nothing weird happens
although they did say they kind of like
smoothed it over with saying eerie
sounds continue to echo through the
house that's what it said um so i don't
know what that means i don't know if
that means like footsteps or knocking or
whatever the hell
um
so like i said john the husband is like
hardly ever around he's always at work
like he's usually working late so he's
not usually around but the rest of the
family is usually there so one night
judy and caressa and lisa and jacob are
sitting in the dining room like at the
dining room table playing cards
and then they start hearing these weird
noises coming from caress's room which
is like down the hall
now at first they don't really think
that much about it like they assume oh
it's just an old house and it's settling
that's what they always say
um there's a big difference between like
it like something settling and like
sounded like some [ __ ] in there
i mean this sounded like something
[ __ ] was in there so the sound
keeps
going so they're like okay we better go
back there and see what the [ __ ] going
on maybe somebody like crawled in the
window or some [ __ ] they said it sounds
like somebody's in there so they go in
the room and nobody's in there
but the closet door which is actually
not like a single door but it's like a
double door that slides
um
it's open
now they don't think this is all that
weird but
uh caressa is like i always close that
closet door always always always i did
not leave it open now of course they
don't believe her you know they're just
kind of like oh maybe you just forgot
and left it open or maybe the wood is
warped and it just slid open by itself
or some [ __ ] like that and she's just
probably like
okay whatever like i'm pretty sure i
closed it
she was like absolutely sure she closed
it but they didn't believe her
so after that apparently like a few
weeks went by without anything weird
happening
so lisa gets a new job
and so they're very excited it's like oh
her and jacob are gonna be able to like
move out and go back out on their own
again
so uh because she got a new job they
decide ooh they're gonna have a party
that evening cause they have champagne
and they're having like a big party or
whatever now a few hours after that
after pretty much everybody has gone to
bed lisa also sees the tv turning on by
itself and flipping through the channels
too
so then judy the mom comes out and says
yeah that [ __ ] was doing that the other
day that's like super weird um
and it's like i thought it was the
remote and so i changed the batteries
but that didn't do jack all right now
now for context
this is real
low-level phenomenon
i'm old as [ __ ]
okay and as an old poltergeist [ __ ]
focus from [ __ ] when i was a teenager
if i get ramped up like back in the old
house i get the tv to turn on
remember that that went on for it was
during the time we were writing that
book
yeah turned on to a lot to it but it was
at the house we lived in before this one
that [ __ ] tv used to come on all yeah
to a screen saver it would just stop
and it would just come on
regularly
and yeah once every few days
it went off every few days for a few
months it did that i would get up in the
morning and go out in the living room
and the tv was on one time the tv turned
on in the bedroom we were in yeah but
usually it was the living room living
room one though for whatever and when
the tv guy came i complained about it he
had no doubt i was told he says that's
not possible
and said tv keeps turning onto this well
when it first started happening i was
like maybe pokey is sitting on the
remote like with her butt and turning it
on with her butt but i was just like i
don't think she'd be doing that and it
happened so often that i was like
there's no way that that pokemon
stop doing it
and then uh that was around the time it
pulled the things down and [ __ ] was
opening doors and ringing ringing the
[ __ ] doorbell outside and opening the
garage door
it was all that same phenomenon but it
was very weak so you've seen it and that
was before i threw the remote you've
seen it yeah you just seen it when it
was weak
yeah when i was a kid it was a lot
stronger
so yeah like to me it wasn't really like
scary i was just kind of like oh neat
you know what i mean when it's real
strong you feel like somebody's watching
you and just bearing down on you
yeah well that happens in this case as
well yeah
uh amanda marie serenity hey jenny and
tom how are you working how are you how
are you doing how are you doing they're
talking about herbal meister yeah we did
a review on that on uh we just did we
did a show on him already yeah well
because that was like a serial killer
and a haunting all wrapped up in one
thing
yeah which i may talk about that towards
the end of this because there are
certain places
for the want of a better word can become
strong with the dark side
yeah
well i think i've been talking that way
as an ex-soldier but [ __ ]
uh of pops terence pops from [ __ ]
ridiculous who's ex special forces guy
he commanded a unit who was in charge of
[ __ ] um abu gharib prison after that
[ __ ] scandal happened
he and his unit took over that
and he said that place was haunted as
[ __ ]
and he's posted it you can find it on he
can tell you what he saw him and a bunch
of other guys
and abu ghad prison was a [ __ ] death
camp saddam was murdering people there
in mass
there were bones floating up to the top
of the sand
and he said that they just sealed parts
of it off it was just where they were
killing dudes in cells and making guys
kill themselves in cells
and it was just a bad place and he you
could feel it and you could see things
phenomenon you could hear things
say and i believe him i believe him yeah
but you can make a place that's
strong with the dark side you're killing
up people in one spot you do a bunch of
evil in one spot you'll leave a mark
behind
as they say on the shiny like burn toast
what is his name [ __ ]
scat man scat man crothers like burnt
toast it leaves a trace behind yeah
well i think i mentioned when we did the
herb bowmeister show i said well i don't
know if i necessarily believe in haunted
places but if any [ __ ] place is
haunted it's probably that place yeah
you got all the bad [ __ ] that happened
there you got an evil perverted
[ __ ] obsessing with these weird
obsessions and sexual obsessions and
strangling [ __ ] dudes and [ __ ] in
this one spot
he's a sexual predator
and he's letting the bodies rot
in certain places and on the property
yeah that that that would
that would do something bad to the
[ __ ] spiritual space-time continuum
which would be like a temple a
sacrificial temple to the gods and weird
[ __ ] like you'd have in mesoamerica that
might
have some strange phenomenon you might
be able to produce
it's all theory i've seen some of it i
haven't seen all of it but just reading
things
you know star wars full of [ __ ] but
based on real stuff
based on taoism and buddhism and
parapsychology
and western philosophies all just kind
of merging together
yeah
yeah
you have ob obe or an nde you'll see
that life isn't what you think it is
this is kind of like a holographic
universe
that you know but [ __ ] whatever go ahead
thank you
universe is weirder than you think it is
reality's weird
yeah no [ __ ] yeah uh but yeah so where
was i okay so um
yeah so lisa sees the tv turning on by
itself judy comes out and said yeah
that's like weird [ __ ] that was doing
that the other day and then so both of
the women are like um this shit's
probably haunted now the first thing
that they thought was maybe this is just
the ghost of judy's dad you know the guy
with the lantern um that's pretty much
the only other reference they made to
the lantern i don't know why they made
such a big deal about it but like i said
the lantern belonged to judy's dad so
they're like okay um maybe it's just the
ghost of dad or grandpa or whatever and
he's just like keeping an eye on us
although lisa made the very uh salient
point of it's like well if he was gonna
haunt us why didn't he start doing it
like a long time ago like when he
actually died because i don't know how
many years he'd been dead at this point
but it seemed like it had been a while
so she's like look he's been dead a
while i don't know why he's just like
now decided he wanted to haunt us that's
a little bit weird
so a few days after that which is like
the following weekend
judy decides she's gonna take the kids
to the mall
now lisa the grown daughter she can't go
with them because she's too busy like
with work
now before they leave caressa the 17
year old daughter is freaking out
because again she had put her earrings
that she was gonna wear like down the
dresser and then went to do something
else and then she came back and one of
them had disappeared
and she couldn't ever find it i don't
think she ever found it
so she comes out and she's being like
super [ __ ] about it she's like you
know everything's disappearing like i'm
having all my stuff is disappearing and
this never happened in the old house and
she's getting like real real [ __ ] uh
aggro about it now uh judy said and i've
kind of made a joke about this but judy
said that caress's personality changed
after they moved into the new house uh
that she got like constantly set off by
minor things and that she'd never been
like that been like that before and i
was just like well to me 17 16 17. i
said that just sounds like teenage girl
syndrome well a teenage boy syndrome too
i mean teenagers in general are just
kind of like well it's a puberty thing
and that's prime time for poltergeist
activity i mean they're kind of [ __ ]
and they're always just kind of like
they think everything is the end of the
world so it's like my one earring
disappeared everything is fun yeah you
know what i mean it just sounds like
poltergeist to me
i mean yeah now so uh so yeah now after
that i don't even know if they went to
the mall or not it's not important now
later that night at about three in the
morning lisa the grown daughter she gets
woken up by what she described as she
said it sounded like a man talking and
actually this was my favorite part
because this will like actually kind of
creep me out because she's like there's
a shot of her and she's like laying in
the bed and all of a sudden
like i don't even know what the guy said
but um because i can't hear all that
good but and it woke her up and she's
like i couldn't understand what he said
yeah it was just like mumbling yeah so
that's good i thought it was just me
i was like because everybody talking
sounds like
sounds like the [ __ ] drive-through
thing then she said she could never
understand what they were saying yeah
but she said okay so this voice like
what garvey she said it sounded
legitimately like it was right outside
of her window like there was a guy
talking right outside her window so she
jumps up out of bed because it woke her
up and she looks out the window and
she's like there's nobody there and
she's like there is absolutely no way
that anybody that was that close to the
window because she said he sounded like
he was right there um would have had
time to like run off without her hearing
them or seeing them you know what i mean
she's like it wasn't kind of a thing
where because they weren't it's not on
the second floor it's all a ground floor
like if you see the house it was just
kind of like an old like 50s it looked
like a 50s style house
like 50s or 60s so it was just like one
story like a um what do they call those
like there's just there's one
bungalow yeah well no
that's not exactly the word i was
looking for i'll think of it in a minute
but yeah it was just kind of like and
i've and like i said if the house is
actually on the street that this person
on pinterest said it was i looked at all
the houses on that street and they
looked like
late 50s early 60s
like just one story
yeah kind of yeah like that ranch house
thank you that's what it was
like a ranch house so it looked like
that so she said you know if there was
somebody out there you know by the time
i jumped up and looked out the window i
would have seen them like running away
or heard them running away and i didn't
see anybody
now she said that once she was awake she
also smelled something it she said it
smelled like something was burning in
the living room
and so she goes out like i said it's
three o'clock in the morning and so she
goes out to check but she doesn't see
anything like everything's fine
now judy the mom had also been awakened
not by the voice but she had been
awakened by the burning smell so they
said they both smelled it oh man i gotta
check the i'm gonna check the uh the
oven oh yeah okay burning smell made me
think
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah he's got like some pork cooking in
the slow cooker and he was just kind of
like oh [ __ ] burning smell i should
probably go check on that but yeah i
mean it's probably fine i think he put
it on like really low for like an hour
but it'll be all right
so yeah so judy was awakened she said by
the same burning smell that her daughter
smelled
so she actually came out to the living
room she was like yeah it smelled like
it was coming from out here
now lisa said hey i heard a man talking
like outside my window so they the two
of them become like ever more convinced
man this place is [ __ ] haunted and i
don't think it's grandpa or dad in
judy's case she's like he wouldn't like
[ __ ] with us like this it's like if this
was dad and or grandpa um you know he
would talk to us directly he would
communicate directly he wouldn't be
pulling this kind of crap so we're
pretty sure it's somebody else now at
this point like the husband john
he gets up
or at least like the actor playing him i
don't know what the real guy was like
because he wasn't on here but uh so i
don't know if he was this much of a
douche but anyway so he gets up and he
comes out and he's just like i have to
get up in three hours and what the [ __ ]
are you and they weren't even being loud
they were just like talking to one
another but whatever so he gets up and
he's like i have to get up in three
hours what the [ __ ] are you guys doing
up here you're keeping me awake yada
yada um and he's a real dick about it
now at this point like i said john
neither john or the younger kid like uh
jacob have seen or heard anything as far
as i know like i said i don't know if it
was just because they weren't on there
so they didn't have anything to report
but even like the little kid didn't
wasn't on there and didn't say he'd seen
anything
so yeah the guy was like well i'm going
back to bed and you should too blah blah
blah and he was just like that and i'm
just like okay special so uh yeah so
nothing weird happens for the next
couple days and lisa is just kind of
like whatever the [ __ ] and she just like
starts forgetting about it
now caressa though
she said that this whole time
she still senses something in her room
like watching her pretty much like all
the time
um she's like it was everywhere like
everywhere she went in the house but
like in her room it was like the most
intense she said
and because of this
she said like for probably a couple of
weeks she didn't get hardly any sleep
you know what i mean because yeah she
thought somebody was watching her like
particularly like i said from her closet
so she wasn't sleeping all that good and
she's getting like kind of cranky now
she starts leaving the light on at night
like maybe that will help
um but she said the whole time i was in
there like i'd be laying in bed and i'd
be like convinced that something was
about to pop out that closet she was
like that's pretty much what it felt
like um now on some nights she actually
gets really scared like by the feeling
and she goes and sleeps in her parents
room
but again her dad is like a real douche
about it and he's just like you are too
old to be sleeping in here why are you
sleeping in your parents room and you're
being irrational and what are you crying
about that never solved anything and
yada yada so there was that whole thing
too so he was like not super supportive
obviously
so at this point judy is like i didn't
really she's like i believed her um
because i you know felt some [ __ ] too
and she's like but i didn't really know
what to do to like protect her
so she's like i did pretty much all i
could think of to do she's like i knew
that i had like a cross in the house
someplace she's like it was in with my
christmas decorations and i don't i
don't know if well i'm assuming they
didn't seem like a particularly
religious family like they never called
a priest at any point or anything like
that which is interesting because most
families on this show
uh will call a priest at some point but
they never did
um i mean she did have the idea maybe a
cross would help i don't know so she
goes and digs around in her in her
christmas decorations which i thought
was like kind of funny but she so she
finds like this kind of cheap ass
looking like a cross she's like i don't
know if they used to hang another
christmas tree or some [ __ ] like that
and so she like puts it over
caress's door like the door to her
bedroom she's like maybe this will help
now caressa at this point because like i
said she was on the show so they
interviewed her and she said well
you know my dad was like she didn't say
this but it was implied her dad was like
yelling at her and didn't really like
her sleeping in the room with the
parents
so she's like so i just tried to even
though i was like super scared i was
trying to sleep in my own room um and
her she did actually say this and this
is a quote she said i tried my hardest
not to think about it i felt like i had
to be strong and tough it out because
like i said the dad was saying stuff
like quit your crying that never helped
anybody blah blah so she was just like
okay well i guess i gotta sleep in here
even though it sucks
so this one particular night though um
she apparently hears the closet door
slide open now i think that this
happened more than once uh they implied
that it happened more than once although
she didn't actually say that but the way
that they kind of like set it up seemed
like it happened more than once that she
was always like hearing the closet door
because like i said she always said she
said she always closed the closet door
like when she was in the room
and it was like two sliding doors like
that
so she said that she would hear it like
sliding open a lot of times and
would it sounded like someone was in
there like somebody was like [ __ ]
you know like moving around in there
like with all the stuff
but she's like she was always too scared
to look so she just lays there in bed
like frozen like not wanting to like
look over at the closet
but this one particular night she hears
that noise and she's like [ __ ] this i'm
just gonna lay here and pretend it's not
happening but she said that suddenly she
felt like there was like something like
a really heavy weight on top of her
and she couldn't breathe so she started
like freaking out and like screaming and
[ __ ] like that
her mom judy runs in and says oh we'll
give you some fresh air i'll open the
windows but they didn't go into this a
lot but apparently like the windows in
her room i don't know about the rest of
the house had been nailed shut so i
don't know if the owners did that or if
like a previous tenant had did that and
i don't really know like i said they
didn't go a lot into that it was just
kind of a thing where it's like oh the
windows are nailed shut and i can't open
them and i was just like well can we
explore like why that is or no but they
never did
so she comes in and the mom comes and
tries to open the windows damage to the
to the that's what i mean where you had
it or if you opened them they'd fall out
of the damn
window frame or something
yeah although there was another case
where somebody would nail the windows
shut that's what ghosts kept opening
them up that's what i was thinking i was
thinking maybe there wasn't any reason
for it and that's why they didn't bring
it up because that's what i was
remembering that there was an i don't
remember what episode it was but there
was another episode where they moved in
and all the windows were nailed shut and
then once they peeled all the you know
they pried all the nails out then the
ghost started like opening the windows
they're like oh well that's why the
person nailed the window shut obviously
because they were sick of them like
opening all the time so i can see that
but like i said i don't know if that was
the situation here they just kind of
went into his like oh all the windows in
her room were nailed shut and though and
the whole heavyweight
not being able to breathe i didn't know
if that was a euphemism of maybe sexual
assault too let me go get uh let me go
put some more ice in that okay i didn't
know if they were trying to say that
what was happening with some kind of sex
spiritual sex i mean that was the
impression that i got but i don't really
want to
say that because i don't know if that's
what was implied because what they did
she just basically said in her interview
she said i felt like there was a weight
on top of me and i couldn't breathe like
she was gagging and choking and stuff
like that in the reenactment
they kind of just showed her like pinned
to the bed with nobody there but then
they would do like flashes of like this
creepy like old ghosty looking dude like
laying on top of her so i don't know if
they were implying i got the impression
they were implying that this was like a
sexual assault by a ghost situation you
know like the entity or something but
she didn't say that so i don't really
want to like put words in her mouth so
there's that so
yeah so all that happens
um
and judy is like starting to like really
worry so she takes caressa actually to
the doctor the next day because of the
not being able to breathe kind of
situation maybe there's something else
going on
now the doctor doesn't find anything
physically wrong with her um and he
thinks maybe you just had like a panic
attack because that's what it sounds
like like when she describes the
symptoms tim he said it sounds like a
panic attack and she says i don't know
if she really told the doctor this in
real life but she's like yeah um the
shit's haunted and i'm not being able to
like sleep or anything because he was
asking if she'd been depressed and she's
like well not really but
you know i'm not getting a lot of sleep
because my room's on it you know what i
mean um so at this point judy has like
kind of had enough so she talks to the
landlord like the landlord comes over to
like fix some [ __ ] or whatever and she's
like well what just hypothetically like
what would happen if we wanted to move
out
and
the landlord like immediately gets like
super hostile and like aggro about it
it's like if you break the lease i'm
suing you and i was like dude let's that
[ __ ] had bills to pay man that i know
that but it's like jesus christ it's
like that's she wouldn't she didn't say
she was going to move she just said
hypothetically like what he just
immediately jumps to i'm going to sue
your ass i'm like okay that's nice
settle down settle down
um now at this point like the husband
and
the landlord even says like on the show
talk to your wife
and i'm just like oh here we go so john
is like we're not moving because you
think there's a ghost yada yada yada so
then like um so judy is just like yeah
but you're never here so you don't know
like what the rest of us are
experiencing so
[ __ ] off you know what i mean but she
doesn't say that but that's kind of
that's what i was thinking i don't know
if she said that or not she should have
probably
um
okay so a few days later now this is
this was kind of like a
that escalated quickly situation so a
few days later uh caressa is actually
home from school not because of she
can't sleep but because she had a cold
or something like that so her and her
mom are like in the kitchen like to
cooking something or whatever and then
suddenly
caressa sees
an apparition like over like it's behind
her mom and it's like in the living room
and she said i mean she didn't say this
exactly but she kind of implied that she
had seen something like this so it's
apparently like a dude and he's walking
through the living room and he either i
couldn't tell if he like disappeared
through the wall
or disappeared down the hall toward
where her bedroom was
so
judy turns around and she apparently
sees it too
and she actually did say on the thing
she's like it's pretty it's crazy like
thinking oh
you know they had already come to the
conclusion that the shit's haunted but
she's like actually seeing it and she's
like and i actually saw him disappear
like that's a whole other [ __ ] level
of [ __ ] at this point
so apparently both of them saw an
apparition they didn't describe it so i
don't really you know i can't really
speak to that but
they apparently did see something and it
freaked them the [ __ ] out
now at this point judy is like panicking
she calls lisa at work and says we saw
the [ __ ] um it's a dude and we're
getting the hell out of this house for a
little while because [ __ ] that which
like i said i get it if i saw that i'd
be yep i'm gonna be out of here for a
little while
so lisa starts doing research to see if
she can find someone to help them and
like i said it's kind of refreshing on
this one that they didn't uh immediately
call a priest
lisa ends up finding a woman named
margaret prescott now she had a
paranormal research team like i said she
didn't say she was a psychic it was
basically just her and her son and they
just came in and did
they they seemed like they did more
scientifically based kind of [ __ ]
neo-parapsychologist
yeah they seemed more into that kind of
stuff she didn't say anything about
psychics or
feeling vibrations or nothing like that
uh i don't know if they mentioned it on
the show
but i did find margaret prescott online
and their the team is called corpus
christi spook central um it's her and
her son like i said
uh her son's name is monty i believe
so lisa finds them and arranges them to
come out like asap
now that night judy tells her husband
john about hey these paranormal
investigators are coming over
and then they kind of like glided over i
don't know if he was like okay with it
maybe it got to the point where he's
just like she's like look we're doing
this [ __ ] because i think we maybe were
in danger and we actually saw some stuff
um and he was gonna be going out of town
anyway so maybe he's just like whatever
i don't really know how that worked out
uh the kid jacob who didn't even really
factor into this he goes to stay at a
friend's house as far as i know the kid
like i said he was 11 or 12 i don't
think he ever saw anything he wasn't on
the show so i don't know i can't really
like uh you know elaborate on that
because he wasn't really a part of the
thing
so at this point margaret
uh you know the paranormal investigator
and her son monty they come in and they
meet with the family and they set up all
the cameras like all around the house
um concentrating mostly on caress's room
because that seemed like where most of
the activity was taking place and monty
like sets up his col whole like viewing
station slash command central whatever
like out in the garage
and then they tell the family look um
you guys need to like leave the house
for a while like while we're doing the
investigation so that anything we pick
up we know that it's not y'all like we
know that it's
you know the that it's maybe paranormal
and not like humans like [ __ ] around
or whatever
so they set up a bunch of like infrared
cameras digital tape recorders they're
like looking to look get evps and [ __ ]
like that
now
apparently while they were finished
getting set up
and they're in the garage like making
sure all the cameras are working because
they have like all the monitors or
whatever
the camera in caress's room which was on
a tripod
uh moves by itself
apparently like it was just kind of like
whoop we're gonna film over there now
margaret is like what the [ __ ] happened
there so she's like i'm gonna go in the
room and check on that and put it back
where it goes
now she said when she went into caress's
room she got the distinct feeling that
whatever or whoever was in the house
really didn't want them there and really
did not want the cameras there either
now uh she's pretty much like and this
is a quote from the show it says uh she
knows that any ghost who can move uh
move something like is powerful enough
to
hurt people you know what i mean so
she's kind of like well that's what i
thought like this is not yeah and that
it's funny when they said that on the
show it was like i thought of you
because they're like anybody that can
just like move [ __ ] around like that i
mean they could easily kill you if they
wanted to they just like drop a concrete
block on your head yeah that's that
reminds me that's what uncle red said he
said for all we know man this thing
could put something on top of a door jam
so when you open it up it'll [ __ ]
drop on you yeah
it never did never did anything like
that though it didn't touch anybody but
lois
she said she felt it grab her around the
leg and go up her waist she said it was
a weird like a snake coiling up around
her
yeah yeah i'm glad it never touched me
out of [ __ ] lost it
yeah that would be like pretty [ __ ]
weird yeah
she said it came out of the floor
wrapped around her leg and went up and
then around her waist and [ __ ] like
it like it jumped off
she did like an invisible snake
imagine that said it was cold so you
could feel the pressure of it though
man
now that you're talking about maybe
that's gonna happen yeah i saw it happen
she's like oh my god whoa whoa whoa that
was followed you a man you're like whoa
she's like that and red was standing
right near what happened it it came up
out of the floor and got me
and i i was i was losing it no no way
no way yeah
tom was very high strong as a child yeah
i was like no way
no way which is probably what caused the
whole poultry yeah and that was after it
through the pillows
it was right after the throw the pillows
threw the pillows and [ __ ] threw the
[ __ ] blanket off the comforter off
weird [ __ ] man yeah
i'm glad i didn't see that
there was [ __ ] i didn't want to see well
like i said if if you were the one that
was initiating it which you probably
were you pretty much
laid down the parameters at first you're
like you know do what you want i don't
want to see you and i don't want you to
touch touch me it never did and it never
did no well like i said because it was
you doing it i think yeah so that's
right i didn't know at the time though
yeah that's true
it's just a certain facet of your
subconscious doing it like a character
out of one of your dreams
yeah you can't control the characters in
your dreams there's certain facets of
you you don't control really well which
is why
when it kind of came back
dimitri dimitri saw it
and [ __ ] his wife saw it he said tom
do it again do it again i was like no no
no i had to stop it from i had to stop
the ball rolling i could feel the ball
started rolling again
because i don't really trust myself
i don't trust you either like i said
you're going to like drop some [ __ ] on
my head one day and smush me
you already like made that [ __ ] fly
off some of the other days some of the
uh some of those other kind of like uh
facets of my personality aren't good
you know what i mean they're like
they're like the [ __ ] i should start
wearing a helmet yeah it doesn't come
out here like
i was i told [ __ ] sofia said you know
sophie listens to the show she's been on
the show she's gonna come back and visit
us one of these days
but uh i said yeah one of them in there
is kind of like venom and it [ __ ]
hates me like that thing it you know and
she goes she told me privately she's
like yeah i have that same one she's a
if there's a part of me that [ __ ]
hates me
yeah i mean i have that part too i don't
think it's quite as extreme as venom but
it's i but i get what you're talking
about yeah it not only does it hate me
it wants to kill me all right another
one is
uh
kind of reminded me of [ __ ] mr hyde
from [ __ ] the the show the mommy
you know what [ __ ] russell crowe
after he threw all those phones
well
man you throw one phone no phone and
this time we'll never land
yeah that phone i [ __ ] got mad
respect for [ __ ] russell
but uh that when russell crowe was
playing the uh uh uh [ __ ] dr jekyll
mr hyde you know mr hyde started talking
it was [ __ ]
familiar i was like yeah
that's kind of like the
the other fascinated me that's just like
lust for power and chaos
i know that one too
so i don't trust these things with
psychic abilities you need to settle
down yeah
and he goes oh they will love us you
know what i mean yeah yeah yeah i don't
want no that because i don't know which
one is doing the psychokinesis though
that's what i'm saying yeah this is why
i don't like man me and pookie are gonna
have to like
get a bunker never heard anybody so it
must not be as bad as though
yeah
you never know
you never know
so yeah
russell crowe in the road rage film was
epic i really i really did like that
what was it called unhinged i think it
was yeah that was a good movie i had a
good time i need that in my collection
it was like so over the top but it was
like it was so great i mean it was over
the top on purpose
okay so
so yeah so the paranormal investigator
margaret uh
yeah she said if if it can move a camera
like that then yeah it could [ __ ] you up
if it wanted to and she says on the show
she said i just had the feeling
that there was something inside the
closet that in carusa's room and it
wasn't very nice that's what she said
so she tries perhaps unwisely i'm not
sure but she wants to provoke the ghost
because she wants to get some evps she
wants to like uh prove that there's
something in here so she basically
starts
i don't know she wasn't like being
aggressive toward him but she was
basically like um you know why are you
in this house like why are you
tormenting this family um proof that
you're in here like move something she's
you know what i mean so she's trying to
like call it out
and she says like show yourself to me
now while she's sitting in there on the
bed like looking out the closet now she
doesn't see anything but her son monty
who's in the garage watching the cameras
like watching the monitors
he said well i don't know if he said but
they said this on the show
that apparently like an orb
came like not just like floating like a
bug or whatever but like came flying out
of the closet like toward her
what was it like an orb an orb okay yeah
so he says to his mom because they can
like because she can hear him he says
hey like an orb just like flew out of
the closet at you so you might want to
like get out of there because the ghost
is obviously pissed
um you know what i mean because he saw
it and she didn't
uh but then she decides she's going to
challenge the ghost even further she's
like hey you want me to leave this room
then you have to make me leave that's
what she said and i was like is this
really the wisest move probably not
now then she said and they did interview
her on the show
she said this really strange feeling
traveled up my legs and started
traveling up to my arms
she said it felt like all the air was
being sucked out of the room like she
couldn't breathe anymore so like i said
that was kind of like what the what the
daughter had reported that she couldn't
breathe
so she's like okay fair enough and runs
out of the room like gagging and choking
like she said it felt like all literally
like all the air was being sucked out of
the room and she couldn't breathe
anywhere just a reminder people the
super chats are open and i'm passing the
[ __ ] collection plate around okay
jenny work hard on the [ __ ] how do i
jenny work hard on this uh i work hard
on everything she works
that's my whole thing
[Laughter]
i do too and i'm glad you do it because
i don't i don't like it yeah it's hard
to beg for yourself i'm begging for
other people well that's what i mean
that's what i say i just i just like to
do my own thing and it's like hey if
people want to like give me money then
that's cool but yeah i'm not gonna let
me uh let me go check the cooking again
okay
so so the family comes back and they're
like okay well what's the verdict and
margaret's like well i got some bad news
for you
uh she says this ghost is very very
powerful and very very
violent uh you're gonna need to do a
cleansing which like to me sounds like a
little bit
like what
there's really nothing you can do in
this situation like if like i said if
any of this is real i don't know like
i'm still like on the fence about it but
they're like well you have to do a
cleansing
so margaret says well i'm gonna try and
find somebody that can do it um but it
might be a few days or a week or
something like that and judy is just
kind of like okay
thank you camp guy thank you very much
like look tom begging like actually like
into something but yeah like thank you
very much
uh so yeah
and judy is like look i can't [ __ ]
wait that long because wait that long
because i'm pretty sure like my daughter
is in danger
uh so maybe
maybe
judy thinks that she can maybe do it
herself
margaret is like well
you could
technically she's like but
one of two things will happen either
everything will work out good and like
the ghost will be like okay fine and
like leave they're like but also the
other option is that the ghost might
just get really really mad at you and
then everything gets like exponentially
worse so
you know you don't know how it's gonna
go
uh but judy's like [ __ ] it i can't wait
for like some specialist and cleansing
to like come in because you know you
know this is like a matter of life and
death apparently that's what she felt so
she's like i'm gonna do some [ __ ] thank
you mrs evans arty party thank you thank
you loving these shows jenny you work so
hard in research thank you oh well
you're very welcome you're both these
are fun though i really like we were
talking before
the stream started
that
we were actually really happy that we
had i don't know why we didn't think of
doing it before but uh we're actually
like really happy that we started doing
these haunting shows again because these
are always like super fun to do like
yeah it's not a lot of work like
watching them but usually what we do is
like we'll watch them in the evening and
then the next day i usually watch the
episode again
um you know so i can take notes about it
and then like i'll research if there's
any other like supplemental material
about you know like i said if somebody
wrote a book about it or if there was
like a local article about it so i'll
try to like try to find other stuff
about it but and then like i'll kind of
like write a timeline of like what
happened and stuff like that but yeah
these are actually like really fun to do
and
hopefully we said [ __ ] oh thank you i
see money man yeah and i got flash bulbs
everywhere thank you very much everybody
gave us money because you left yeah yeah
i'm okay
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
nobody's sorry i'm just i'm just [ __ ]
with you yeah i'm just [ __ ] with you
um but yeah so
but we were talking earlier like before
the stream started that um then i was
like holy [ __ ] like even if we talked
about every single episode of haunting
it's like that's
like years and years worth of content
and then we can do paranormal and then
like i said and there's so many other
ghosts we could do like the pet one the
one with that we could do paranormal
witness ghost animals ghost hunters it's
not even called that i know
it doesn't even have anything to do with
animal or anything which is like it is
an on animal planet or it used to be i
don't know
and it was
not bad it wasn't bad yeah i didn't mind
it it wasn't as cool like i said it
seemed a little shoehorned but that's
okay
and i mean if you if we wanted to get
like really [ __ ] lick we could talk
about uh like the one with zach baggins
on it because that one i don't remember
which one's that isn't that ghost
hunters that was like the og yeah
that's what i mean i don't really know
if i want to sit through those because
they're not fun i like the ones that are
more like reenactments i don't really
like the ones with other than ghost
brothers which i actually really like
this was funny because though guys those
guys were actually like funny and
entertaining yeah and weren't like
didn't take themselves too seriously
which i appreciated but the the other
kind of ghost hunter shows usually it's
just like people wandering out in a dark
room like with that green like night
vision [ __ ] going like did you hear that
i'm like no i didn't hear anything okay
i didn't hear anything no oh stop it of
the ghost hunter ones ghost brothers was
the most entertaining one two black
dudes
going to hold on those little black
dudes three black dudes that's right
going to haunted locations scaring the
[ __ ] out of each other did they find
anything no no but at least like i said
at least they don't [ __ ] out of each
other at least they don't take it
seriously yeah yeah
and they're like
they kind of do but like because they
would get tripped out they're like oh
this is bad in here [ __ ] you know but
they're just like entertaining they were
just like entertaining and like their
interactions were interesting yeah they
were funny they were they were good
dudes yeah
i just feel like a lot of the other ones
like i said is people taking themselves
too seriously and they're just kind of
like this person was murdered and i was
just like shut up sound like a good job
you're not going to have any
someone who's seen what you would call a
paranormal phenomenon you're not going
to see it within the context of a
[ __ ] show that happens in 30 minutes
where a whole crew of people show up and
film something in a few hours and go it
you got to live in those locations
that's what i mean so i always kind of
feel like they always have like some
member of the crew hey like why don't
you go in that other room and like move
a chair or something yeah like something
happens on the ship yeah i always kind
of feel like that's probably what's
going on did you hear that and
poltergeist phenomena is totally
spontaneous you can't predict it and
when outside people come in witnesses to
see it it stops at least for a while
and then it builds back up but we did
have a couple witnesses to ours [ __ ]
jimmy it was
a [ __ ] red's buddy who worked at
[ __ ] round table pizza back in those
days and it scared the [ __ ] out of him
and we never saw him again
after he saw it he never never saw him
again
never spooked me out when i said red he
never came back he says no he never came
back
yeah he was like that and they were
friends for a long time so he never
never came back you saw some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in the house yeah saw some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and he never came back yep
and then uh our club friends
demetri and jen
they get on here and tell you that yeah
the remote picked up and flew
yeah they all saw it they all saw it
yeah nobody was touching it nope
yeah
but yeah and i was old when i did that
that was only a few years ago two years
ago yeah like what was it just in the
right minds three or four years ago
something like that yeah and then the
stack of coins at my feet yeah weird
weird
but yeah so uh so at this point judy's
like okay well
this is like no i can't control it yeah
you have to think it's outside force
if you try to do it on your own and
force it to happen it won't do it
you have to channel it
it's gotta and you have to believe that
it's an outside force doing it
which kind of goes back to some of the
[ __ ] buddhists and taoist
philosophies and [ __ ] that you hear like
in
star wars that you that
the force is flowing through
someone the person isn't making the
force it's flowing through it you're
channeling it it's not you or it's the
power of god doing it it's not you
you know moses did things by the power
of god that's what these stories are
talking about
did moses actually happen i don't think
so but um
it it still follows the laws that i
witnessed
if you think it's you that's it won't do
it
it's too that's
too arrogant i guess although maybe if
you were to [ __ ] go headlong and go
no it's me and you have like a super
[ __ ] psychopathic egotistical
personality you might be able to do it
by force of will
but it'd probably be pretty evil
you know
kind of i don't know i don't talk about
anymore
okay
all right well it's like what the
[ __ ] emperor said go kill all the
children of the jedi temple after that
only then will you be strong enough in
the dark side to [ __ ] save padme
so you got to do some evil [ __ ] to get
the [ __ ]
confidence up to be that self-centered
and that's psychopathic to to do it now
i think it's just an example i don't
know if things things like that actually
happen
but i think i think lucas is pulling
through a [ __ ]
echo of [ __ ] stories of the past and
just
reading into what was written in ancient
times and going yeah that's what they're
talking about sorcery necromancy what
they're talking about
yeah
okay
all right so at this point uh like i
said the
you know the paranormal lady margaret
she's basically like well you could do
the blessing yourself the cleansing
rather she didn't do a blessing um but
it either might make everything better
or it might make everything like a lot
worse and judy's like well you know this
is a life or death situation i can't
risk it i'm going to do it myself i
can't wait for like some expert to come
in here and do it
so she gets a bible from someplace and
uh everyone's gone like everybody's left
like for work or for school so she's at
home by herself and she basically just
goes with a bible from room to room
basically just telling the spirit to
like get the [ __ ] out like why are you
here like get the [ __ ] out of here
now she saves caresses room for last
now when she gets in there she said
that she felt as though someone was
standing right beside her
and that she was having trouble
breathing which is again like the very
common thing for for this room
apparently
now the show like the reenactment was
like real dramatic there was kind of
like a mystery wind like blowing through
the actress's uh tragic haircut and you
know blowing the curtains around and
[ __ ] like that and there was like a
bunch of noise and everything now she
didn't say that she saw all that crazy
[ __ ] although i think she did say later
that she heard knocking on the walls
while she was doing
the
the cleansing or the blessing or
whatever but black frog is trying to
send us money but it's purchase isn't
going through for some reason
we can uh jenny can also do um cash app
and paypal and paypal
but you know whatever right and we still
get the money
yeah
yeah
okay so
after all of that
um she goes to margaret's office like
the paranormal office and tells her what
happened
and margaret says well the fact that you
heard all that knocking and that you
felt somebody standing next to you like
while you were doing the cleansing that
probably means like the ghost is pissed
and isn't going to leave so
she didn't say you [ __ ] it up but
she's basically like well that's wha i
warned you that would probably happen
you just made the ghost mad
and she's like oh and by the way
you got to listen to this [ __ ]
so she plays julian evp that she got in
the house like the night they were there
and this was and i'm sure this wasn't
the actual one because it was like super
super clear but she plays an evp
and it's a man's voice very clearly
saying
i'm here for the girl
so apparently this ghost is a [ __ ]
pervo
who's obsessed with caressa the 17 year
old daughter yeah
margaret also says by the way i
researched your house and discovered
that there was a murder there 20 years
ago
where it was like a drug related thing
it was like a drug dealer shot another
drug dealer and then set the house and
or the body like on fire to cover the
crime up which
she's like that's probably why you guys
smelled
smoke um
and
so margaret i guess suspects that like
the murder victim is the one haunting
the place and that the voices on stuff
that they heard were like replays of the
night of the murder
that's what that was her theory anyway
now at this point judy is like pretty
frightened for the safety of her
daughter and is finally able to convince
her
skeptical husband john we need to
[ __ ] move
so they do actually end up finding
another house nearby and lisa and jacob
actually move out to their own apartment
across town now as they're packing up
the last few things in the house though
like to move away
caressa goes into her old room because
there's like one more box she needs to
get like i said i don't know if this
happened or not um but yeah it was just
like that one more box and then we can
leave so she goes in there to get it and
while she's in the room like the door
slams and locks and she can't get it
open and she starts like panicking and
like freaking out right
and of course she can't climb out the
window because as we mentioned earlier
the windows are nailed shut
now in her room there's like an air duct
situation that like leads out into the
hall you know what i mean like it's just
kind of like this kind of open turn yeah
like the little panel where there's like
yeah it's one of those
so uh so she opens that and then her mom
and dad are out in the hallway and
they're trying to like pull her out so
they're like give me your hands or
whatever so they're like pulling her
and then apparently the ghost is trying
to like pull her back into the room like
from inside there i'd like to know the
real account but yeah see i don't know
like the way they talked about it it
kind of sounded like what they showed
but they probably exaggerate it for the
show and imagine you're pulling around
one side and something else is pulling
her on the other yeah she said they said
it felt like someone was pulling her
from inside the room yeah like i'm like
on the show they kind of pull like an
invisible what's this was like pulling
her legs like from this side and they
were pulling her from the arm to this
side like she's really gonna tear it in
half like a loaf of bread but um you
know what i mean
but
i don't know i don't know what it really
looked like in reality but they did seem
to say that it felt like someone was
pulling her from the other side
but apparently they do like pull her out
and they hightail it out of this house
never to return now caressa later on
went back to normal everything went back
to normal she graduated from high school
not long afterwards she got a job
everything was uh was fine now
i will note i was curious to see if
there had really been a murder that
happened in this particular house and
now like i said i couldn't find the
actual address of this house although
on pinterest somebody had taken a
picture of what they purported to be
this house and they said it was in the
1200 block and the street hayward drive
is not that long
so i was basically like googling
uh you know see if there was a murder in
that on that street like on because they
said when they moved in it was 2005 and
they said oh the murder happened 20
years ago which would have been 1985
and
i found like a couple murders in corpus
christi around that time but i couldn't
really find it i'm not saying there
wasn't one i'm just saying that
if there was one
it wasn't um you know it hasn't been
digitized like the newspaper or whatever
i didn't really find anything
um that happened on that street well
there were some murders that happened on
that street but it wasn't like the same
situation what they said was that
it was apparently like a drug related
thing that's pretty much all they said
like a drug related thing one guy came
in and shot another guy and then set him
on fire or set the house on fire and
they obviously didn't burn the whole
house down because it was still there
but
but i couldn't find anything like that
i'm not saying that it didn't happen i'm
just saying that i didn't find anything
like that so
i don't know so i don't know like how
much of the history of the house i
couldn't really find that much else
about the house outside of this show
so i don't really know how much i'm not
saying they're lying like i said i'm
just saying just couldn't find anything
else i'm just gonna find anything
outside of it like any kind of like
corroborating what the show is saying is
this
i'm going to say this in paranormal and
hollywood terminology from the
paranormal so you all can understand
what we're talking the show is saying
that a young
charismatic woman
in a primal life good genes highly
energetic
moves into an area where something bad
happened
it's a place that's
kind of
place is kind of [ __ ] you know strong
with the dark side
and some kind of fragment or memory of
the past she's able to energize it or it
sees her
and goes after her
that's what that's basically what and
then she
later on you know it does a little
phenomena and then they have to get her
out of there that's what the story says
because honestly something like that
it seems like most of the phenomena was
centered around her like other people
saw stuff like the mom saw stuff the the
adult daughter also said she saw stuff
but most of the bad stuff that happened
seemed to be centered around that yeah
it sounds like poultry guys teenagers it
sounds like poultry guys to me which is
like something out of shiny
seeing a fragment of the past and kind
of bringing it bringing it to life for
you and others
your psychic abilities bringing this up
back in into reality
um
now
in a situation like that this dead
person are they really there no i don't
think so
you're somehow reanimating a memory of a
certain aspect of that person
and yeah maybe that person would have
wanted would have been attracted to you
you know what i mean you know and
[ __ ]
there's kind of a [ __ ] lust element
to it
do i think that that there was a ghost a
full-fledged ghost of a dude dude in
there creeping around in her closet i
don't think so
i don't think so
i think it was a fragment of a person
or or a memory this year seriously if i
woke up in the middle of the night in
our closet door open by itself i would
[ __ ] [ __ ] a brick yeah
having a poltergeist experience a
near-death experience and an out-of-body
experience based on what i saw when i
was out of body on those two times
your if you die
or you come close to death or if you
exteriorize yourself
even if it's spontaneously in an
out-of-body
experience you tend to want to gravitate
higher into higher realms which i would
i would characterize as heavens
and i was kind of instantly understood
that if you continue to go i don't want
to say up because up is not really what
it is more like higher frequencies
more if you continue to go in that
direction you naturally gravitate
towards it
you won't come back
later on
reading
reading things led me to to envision
where you go is
what the greeks called the pleroma it's
the place where gods come from and where
souls come from it's the place where
consciousness comes from if you go into
that you enter a singularity you don't
come back
star wars to say some people learn to
come back from becoming one with the
force
that's then you come back as a goat i
but that's i felt like uh if you can if
you go up you vanish
you become one with the sea of souls
um
but it's plausible
because
even in the brief moments where i was
kind of exteriorized
you're kind of connected to a cosmic
internet
i knew that there were
things that were closer to this realm
that were just fragments of the past
they were kind of like the insects
of the spirit world
memories they weren't full
consciousnesses though they weren't
people per se
they were just kind of like
things little evil things kind of they
weren't
fully conscious though
so maybe she saw something like that
a piece of a person that was left behind
because you know a soul can be kind of
it's not really a solid object and
and a soul could cast off a bad part of
itself and then go somewhere else and
that bad part of that soul
is doesn't die it's life energy it can
continue in this other dimension that
i'm talking about
um they might evolve into something else
or dissipate i don't know
i don't know they didn't have time
enough to experiment with it
but uh that's probably what happened
that's that's my idea
she somehow
she was in good condition young
charismatic
high energy
good genetics
she goes into a place where something
bad happened and she gained access to it
and energized it
it came for
but it wasn't a full person it was a
piece of a person a piece of a soul
it'd be a good way to describe it
but it wasn't probably dead it wasn't
dangerous to begin with it's just her
seeing it
and it's doing phenomena and like i said
i haven't heard it there there haven't
been any further reports that anything
else happened at that particular yeah
you would go in there nothing would
probably happen it was just she was able
to access it in that area
she was the right kind of person for it
at that time in place
that's what i think it was danny rowling
said can i be a blue wrench please you
could be you know what i don't know if i
can do it from here anymore i'm gonna
have to like go back like through
youtube and do this [ __ ] because can i
maybe maybe you can do it oh that's
right i meant to make you like i can't
do it oh you know what i will make you
another
uh moderator like on here and then
you'll be able to do okay i just i meant
to do it before i thought we did it
before you just pressed it and you could
make a person well yeah but i could do
it but that was when i was going through
youtube now i'm just going through obs
okay so i can't like there's dots there
but they don't do anything they don't do
anything okay they're just they're just
for show i guess
but i don't know but yeah so i mean
we'll eventually like make you but yeah
we got like all kind of look at all the
porn bots yeah porn bots in a way it's
just kind of like i don't know they
don't really bother me that much because
i was like is that really like working
and it's like well
they wouldn't put be putting porn bots
in the show if like we didn't have right
and a big enough following honestly
every time i post a video the first
two or three comments i get are always
porn bots
usually german nowadays danny you post
comments and they vanished a couple
seconds later i don't know if that's the
kind of setting you have or what
all right uh so is that it i think so
yeah okay so that's it i got to go down
there to take care of the uh the cooking
yeah we gotta we gotta eat some food
it's about dinner time yeah i'll start
setting it up so all right so thanks
everybody for dropping by today thanks
for super chats
and we will be back tomorrow and we're
going to be talking about the 1987 movie
the untouchables that's we're going to
be talking about tomorrow
so
thank you everybody for hanging out with
us this evening and we will see you
again tomorrow evening
bye